- Brendon, you want to be a writer?
You can't write!
You have to actually take an
action that moves you forward.
Getting very clear on the mission.
I think doubt is one of the
greatest enemies of our lives.
So if you don't want to go to
a meeting, sit down and say,
guys, I have 45 minutes
today for this meeting.
The time to have the map is
before you enter the woods.
Get back in the game where
you have a community of people
who are giving you advanced
feedback before you release it.
You just start trying
to live a life that's
not even our own.
I had, nobody had ever really told me
I had any potential before.
I have to change myself.
- He's an American author on
motivation, high performance,
and online marketing.
He's the founder of the Experts Academy
and High Performance Academy.
He's the number one New York
Times bestselling author
of The Millionaire Messenger.
He's Brendon Burchard and here are his
top 10 rules for success.
(dramatic sibilant music)
- No matter where you are
in accomplishing your dreams
or moving towards the things
that you really want in life,
never let your small beginnings
make you small minded.
It's easy to say, well, that's impossible.
And I know lots of people
are telling you that,
that's impossible.
Do you know how many people told me
what I'm doing today is impossible?
Brendon, you want to be a writer?
You can't write!
Brendon, you want to be a
trainer, you want to be a speaker,
you want to do YouTube videos?
You're not good on video,
you're not good at this,
you're not good at this, it's impossible,
oh, you don't understand how
hard it is to make it, Brendon.
It's so hard these days.
The stuff that people tell
me and I know have told you
is so nonsensical and based
on so many of their own fears
that have been unexplored that it's sad.
And it can really cause
great people to stop
trying to do great things.
So I want to encourage you,
no matter where you are,
believe in yourself, keep at
it, keep working, keep going.
I mean, success and fulfillment
are going to come from your
unflagging ability to believe in what
other people call impossible.
It's going to come from your
unflagging ability to get up
each day and work towards
things that maybe you don't know
where they're going.
Maybe they're not getting
you what you want right away.
Maybe it's not easy,
maybe it is a struggle,
but it is through that
struggle and that effort
and that dream and the
desire that you get there.
You have to actually show up
everyday and inch yourself
forward toward these dreams.
And not only show up
everyday and once in a while
inch yourself, I mean everyday
you have to actually take
an action that moves you forward.
Not just research, not just thinking.
Look, the power of intention
is great but without
any initiative it's dead, right?
A dream is great but without
any movement, it's dead.
You have to be moving towards it everyday.
You can send an email everyday,
you can make a call everyday,
you can write something everyday,
you can create something everyday,
you can contribute something everyday,
but it has to be daily.
Otherwise it will never become actualized.
The highest performers in
the world didn't get there
because they were lucky.
They worked at it longer
than everyone else.
They had a better work ethic
and it's not that they didn't
necessarily always worked
harder, they worked smarter
because they were doing the research,
they were taking the time
to visual how they would be
distinct, different, how they
would survive the tough times.
They really kept at it.
Keep every single day momentum going.
And if you don't do
that, there's no chance.
You must define your mission.
You need to have a mission
for what you're doing today.
You need to have an intention
for what your next task
is going to be.
What happens is most
people just kind of show up
and they go, okay, well,
I guess I'll do some stuff
but they have no intention
whatsoever so they end up doing
too many things that mean
nothing towards their mission.
You should figure out what
is it you desire in life?
And figure out the steps to get there
and start working a plan
to get there and minimizing
everything else, getting
very clear on the mission.
Very clear on the mission
and working the plan.
Everything else, guess what it gets?
A no.
Until you reach that mission
or until you're significantly
on your way that you have
free resources to be able
to focus elsewhere.
And that's what people do.
They take on too many
projects because they're not
clear about their mission.
Because, I'm guessing, if
you're watching this, you know,
you're somebody who wants to
add value and make a difference
in the world.
So, anytime someone asks you
to do something you're like,
yeah, let me help you.
But that might not have
anything to do with the quality
of life or the objective or
the thing that you're trying
to achieve or the service you're
really intending to offer.
Right?
And I know how hard it is
because I'm so pulled myself
towards causes and towards
volunteerism and towards helping
so many people.
But guess what?
If I help everybody in
lots of different areas,
I might not make my ultimate
mission of serving the people
I want to serve the most.
Of making my dreams comes true
so I can support more people,
of running my business so
I can support more people.
Meaning it's easy to take
your eye off the ball
if you don't know what the ball is.
And people often have never
defined their mission.
And if you don't have one
right now, for this day,
if you didn't have a drive,
a mission, a written down
statement about what you're
going to accomplish today,
a checklist, a goal sheet,
a time management tool
that you filled out today and
you're just showing up today
and going, well, I guess I'll
see what my inbox tells me
to do today.
And you just respond to
everybody else's desires
and everyone else's emails
and you're just always
in reaction, always
responding to everybody,
no proactivity towards a mission
that you defined yourself,
you'll be lost.
You'll find that because you
never focused on that one
thing or moving towards those
several things that were
your priority, that you're just lost.
Because here's another thing.
Focus goes out the window
when we don't have progress.
Right?
If we're not progressing
towards something,
our focus goes out the window.
We just don't pay attention to anything.
We don't feel good about ourselves.
You want to get more focus in
your life, get more progress.
As you progress more,
you start to get excited,
you start to pay attention to
the things that are working
that are moving you forward
and you start to find
more focus in your life.
The first enemy we all have is doubt.
You know, we doubt whether
or not we're capable,
we doubt whether or not we're worthy,
we doubt whether or not we'll succeed,
we doubt whether or
not we even deserve it,
and it's so unfortunate
because I think doubt is
one of the greatest enemies of our lives.
And it's so easy to overcome
but most people won't practice
the discipline of overcoming
it, which is weird, right?
They say, oh, I'm so
doubtful, and they stop.
And it's like, if you have
any negative recurring emotion
in your life,
doesn't maturity require
you to face it and say,
hey, how do I fix this?
You know?
If you're always doubtful,
you can't just wander around
saying, oh, I'm so doubtful,
like some kind of victim.
That's not fair to the
humanity you've been given,
that real power of free
will that says, hey,
you can direct your
consciousness, that's why you have
this big prefrontal cortex.
Other animals can't, we can.
So, handle it.
If you've been plagued
with doubt your whole life,
then face it, stop running from it.
I know that sounds hard
to say to people but I had
the same story.
I was so doubtful that people
would care about what I say.
would want to read my books
or listen to me at all.
I was so doubtful that I
could chase my own dreams
then I realized, for what
reason am I doubtful.
Because of past failures in this space?
No, I'm trying something new.
Because people told me I
might not be able to do it?
So, what makes them an
expert on my capabilities
and my potentialities?
I thought, well, why am I so doubtful?
We're doubtful because the
germ of fear spread in our body
because somebody planted it
there one time or we cultivate
it with our own thoughts.
And at some point maturity
and consciousness says
if doubt has been plaguing
you, let's have a look at it.
And let's realize, well,
how do you banish it?
Well, every single thing that
we know from spirituality,
from philosophy, from the great
writers and the great texts
of human culture has
all revealed one thing.
Where there is doubt, grant me faith.
That we have to have faith.
And faith does not mean
the absence of doubt.
Matter of fact, the very
definition of faith relies that
doubt is still there, right?
You can't have faith unless
there's some part of you
that says, well, I'm going to
go anyway despite the doubt.
So I'm not saying that we have
to get rid of doubt forever
and handle it.
I'm saying doubt should never
prevent you from advancing
when you feel like advancing.
That in your own mind you must say, okay,
I must trust in my abilities,
I must trust that I will figure it out,
I must trust that I can build it,
I must trust that I can get some help,
and progress even though
the doubt might be there.
Look, the hero is a hero
because the hero does it anyway.
Right?
Even though the hero is
terrified and risking it all,
goes anyway and we're
all heroes in some way.
We can all be courageous.
But I also think society
overblows courage.
Society says, you know,
courage has to be some big
magnificent act but it's not.
I mean, courage in this
world, anymore, is just having
the belief in yourself and
having the ability to genuinely
express who you are.
If you're doubting yourself,
the only way through
is to give yourself more
faith and take more action.
And with more faith and more
action comes more competence.
With more competence
comes more confidence.
In psychology, they call it
the competence/confidence loop, right?
The more you learn and try, the
more you master and develop.
So, go out there, even without,
yes, let the doubt be there,
but do it anyway.
Be more explicit in
communicating your boundaries.
communicating your time.
So if you don't want to go to
a meeting, sit down and say,
guys, I have 45 minutes
today for this meeting.
I can't go a second over.
And they're like, oh, okay.
And stop going over on your times.
If you said you were going
to work out for an hour,
work out for an hour, stop, go.
A lot of the what I
call bleed time ends up
taking away from our balance.
Bleed time is those things
where you go over on things
that you didn't need to go over on.
You know, that one cocktail
with your friend ended up
being 16, you know, and you
lost the entire night now.
Or that one lunch meeting you
were going to have turned into
four hours and now you've
lost the day of work.
Or that one show you were
going to watch before getting
back to work turned into a whole season.
And you're like, oh, no!
The day, the night is gone!
That's called bleed time.
It's where so much time
just dissipates because
you didn't stick to your mark.
So, set your boundary,
communicate it clear with people,
and don't go over on things anymore.
A lot of people, if they just
started with the intention
said, we're only going to
do this for this much time
and then we got to go,
if they stuck to that,
they would get better balance.
If you're really going to get ahead,
you have to study your craft.
You have to deeply study it.
You know, I decided, what
was it now, 18 years ago that
I wanted to help inspire and
motivate people and I wanted
to coach people one-on-one on motivation
and on high performance
and I wanted to write books
on the topics.
So, 18 years ago, I started
reading a book a week
on psychology, leadership,
communication, marketing,
anything I could get in my
hands about human behavior
and high performance.
I was studying everything
I could on psychology
every single week.
Now, it's like people, like wait,
you've read a book a week for 17 years?
And I don't brag about it.
I'm not like, oh yeah, look at me.
That was for my passion.
I knew if I really wanted
to succeed at something
I had to study it and I
had to study it deeply.
And I couldn't, you know,
spend all this time doing all
the other things, so I
had to study my craft.
The great artists of our past
history, that's what they did.
They did one thing.
They had a true level of
depth of study in that area.
Now, maybe they dabbled
in some other areas, too,
but they became famous
because they studied one area.
And so what's your area?
What's the thing you need to study on?
Develop a deep level of
competence into how to do it
and how that world works.
Because, you know, we have
this saying in Montana
that the time to have the map
is before you enter the woods.
But a lot of people have
a dream and they run out
into the woods and they
just start trying stuff
and they take this path, and
this path, and this path,
and this path, and because they
didn't study best practices,
they some day they wake
up and they're lost,
they're confused about who
they are and where they're at
and they're in this dark
forest of the unknown
with no plan to get out.
They had no idea.
They just jumped into something.
They didn't study before taking that leap.
And I would say, you know
what, study, pay attention,
learn from the best, model
the most intelligent,
smart, successful people
you can in any given area
that you want to succeed in in your life
before you get into it.
Then, develop competency by
doing it over and over and over
and over again.
Don't do it once in a
while, here and there.
Over and over and over.
That's how you get competence.
You need to get in a community
where you can get feedback.
You need either a coach who
can give you some direct
one-to-one feedback or a
community of friends who you just
go out with, maybe you go to
lunch with them once a month.
You share everything you're doing,
they give you some feedback.
Or you shoot a video, you send
that video out to everybody
and get some feedback on it.
You create a PowerPoint,
practice it with five people
before the big meeting.
Like, get back in the game
where you have a community
of people who are giving
you advanced feedback
before you release it.
Feedback before you do it
so that you get smarter
at all of this because nothing
makes a dream come more
into life than when you
start getting feedback
from other people about your
movement toward the dreams.
You know?
Before I shoot a big
sales video for one of
my online courses, I'll
send it out to 15-20 people
and get feedback and then I'll
often go re-shoot it again.
Or I'll put it out into
my community and I'll see
the clicks, the conversions,
and say, it's not,
let's do it again and it's that
willingness to get feedback
that will keep your dream
alive because, look,
if it's just in your mind
and you're just doing it
by yourself but you never
actually get a positive community
giving you constructive
feedback towards it,
it will never be in the social realm.
And when it is in the social realm,
it feels more real, you know?
When people are actually
commenting, I mean,
it's one thing to be an
artist and in your studio
painting for yourself
all day, that's great.
But once you get some feedback on it
and constructive feedback, you become,
you get that self awareness
and that social awareness
to contribute and create at another level.
What is it you're really after
and is it after what you,
are you after enough for yourself?
Are you limiting yourself based on
your current competencies?
A lot of people do that.
They narrow they their vision
or their ambition for tomorrow
based on what they can do
today or who they are today
without realizing they
can develop their mastery,
their skills, their
competencies, their knowledge,
their experience.
Without realizing it, they
can become a better person,
they can live into their highest self,
they can live into the type
of person who could accomplish
those goals, who could have those things.
So never limit your ambitions
based on your current competencies.
Never limit yourself today based on
your current inadequacies because those
can be irrelevant tomorrow.
The main thing is to have aim in life.
To have your own aim, to
have your own ambitions,
not the ambitions somebody
told you you should have
or someone told you you're
supposed to be after
because that's how we all
get on sort of, you know,
sometimes a corporate treadmill
or we get on those things
where we just start trying to live a life
that's not even our own
because we're just going with everybody.
But ambition liberates that.
Your individual ambition,
who you want to become.
What you want to do.
What you want to contribute.
And the highest forms of all
ambition usually come down to
your creative expression,
your contribution,
and your connection with others.
That creative expression.
What is it you want to create
in this world and, I mean,
get your hands dirty doing?
You know?
Not just create some
PowerPoint once in a while
for some corporate thing but
something real and meaningful
that you consider art for
yourself, whatever that is.
Even if it is a PowerPoint
presentation, right?
But to do something that you
find artistic and meaningful,
that's our human drive
for creative expression.
Then, what about contribution?
What's your ambition to give
and to serve greatly for others?
What do you really want to
give back or give to others?
What is it?
And what about connection?
You know, the ultimate ambition
and aim to have, I think,
for a lot of people is
their relationships.
To operate and have a
love that knows no bounds,
a love that is extraordinary,
that is amazing.
You can't improve your
relationship with your family
or your spouse or those that
you serve unless you have
in some sense about you
the desire to love or give
or connect more.
So today, get clear.
What is it that you want and
is it big enough for yourself?
Not limiting yourself
based off your inadequacies
or your competencies, but
based on what you truly desire.
Last challenge, take whatever
that is that you come up with
and 10x it.
Take it by 10 times.
What would be 10 times that ambition?
Not just because it's silly, I know,
I know it's kind of silly
but to take that ambition
that you initially have, which is usually,
what we usually want
is an impulse based on
who we are today.
And I just challenge people,
think bigger for yourself
because you are immense,
you are magnificent,
you are powerful beyond
your current understandings.
So break through that on another level.
Challenge your brain to think
even bigger for yourself.
Even if it's just as an
activity to break the bounds
of your current beliefs and behaviors.
You deserve something
extraordinary in your life
but at first, you have to want it.
What makes a great person these days?
What really makes someone extraordinary,
what makes somebody stand out?
What's going to make you
feel like you're contributing
your best, like you're
making your difference,
and that you're always
aspiring to be a better human
but you're also achieving along the way.
I would argue that that thing
that makes us great is generosity.
You know, the ability
to be generous to others
with your time, your
attention, your mentorship,
your care, your love, your
patience, your forgiveness,
your understanding, your
spirit, your energy!
When you are generous with who you are,
people vibrate with that,
they feel it, they sense it
and they're surprised by it.
In a world today where no
one will even take time
to say hello or to call
somebody or to show a measure
of appreciation, when you
do that, you stand out
but you also light up in your soul.
You know, it changes
everything when you're willing
to be different, when you're willing
to be generous with people.
Because, really, you know,
it's a very biblical thing,
ask and you shall receive.
I also think that in terms
of career and in terms
of chasing your dreams,
give and you shall receive.
You know?
Give as much of your heart
and your spirit and your life
and your voice to this
world, this time, this day,
this person in front of you
because we only get one shot
at this life.
And today it never
happens, you don't see it.
You know, I'm blessed to be
here and shooting this video
at my writer's villa where I come to write
and now shoot these episodes.
And I could share with
you, you know, all this,
when I got here, and what
I think about this space,
it came from a position of generosity.
And it came from a position
of generosity in my life
so long ago when I had a high
school mentor, Mrs. Bellew,
who believed in me.
She saw me take some pictures
and she said, you know,
those pictures are pretty good.
Even though, honestly, looking
back, they were kind of crap.
But she'd cheered me on anyway
because I was putting effort
and she was see I was kind
of passionate about it.
And she said, you know,
you could probably write,
and you could probably shoot
these photographs, and I had,
nobody had ever really told
me I had any potential before.
And here was this person
for no reason saying
you could probably do this.
And I started doing it and she'd
cheer me on and cheer me on
and her generosity of her time,
her effort, her mentorship,
she wasn't, there was
no reason she did it,
she just believed in me.
But you know what, she believed
in everybody around her.
She was always cheering people
on, always rewarding effort,
always telling people
to pursue their passions
and believe in themselves.
And I'm here today, I get
to do this work with you,
and millions of people see
these videos and hear me online,
or watch my posts
online, or read my emails
every single week because
this woman, who was a teacher,
at a simple high school in a simple town
with a simple, beautiful
generous spirit said,
I believe in you, kid.
I remember when I was going
to start my business and I
really wanted to be good at it.
You know, I was trying to
become and author and a speaker
and do these types of videos
and do some online training
for people on the topics
of motivation and marketing
and, you know, all these people
were saying, well, Brendon,
you may or may not be
successful with that,
you're, you know, blah, blah, blah.
And I thought, it's a weird thing.
It's not like there's a
trait of successful people.
You look across history
and successful people,
it's not, they're not
from a given background,
they don't come from a
specific economic stature,
they're not in a position where, you know,
they're at one demographic
or another demographic,
I mean, it's all over.
I mean, we've got thousands of
collective years of history.
People succeed, some people
do, some people don't,
and I think it more comes down
to how do we manage our mind?
And how do we manage our days?
And I think that there's a
difference between successful
people and unsuccessful people
in the way that particularly
think about approaching something new.
You know, I think unsuccessful
people, when they have a big
dream and they start thinking
about what's going to be
required to accomplish that
dream, they get very limiting
in their beliefs about
themselves and what's possible.
And specifically they say
three types of things.
You know, the first thing they
often say is well, you know,
I don't know how to do that.
So they stop.
They say, you know, I
don't have those things.
So they stop.
Or they say, I don't know, you know,
I'm not like those
people, I'm not like that.
And so they stop.
But successful people
have a different way,
they have the same thing.
Everybody dreams, you dream, I dream,
successful people dream,
people just starting out,
everybody dreams, everyone has a vision.
Everyone, if they could
just take five minutes today
and think about their
lives, we could all come up
with ways to improve our
lives and reach another level
of success, joy, happiness,
achievement, contribution,
fulfillment, soul, you know?
We can all elevate but
the challenge is that
the unsuccessful people they
keep stopping when they think
of what they currently know, have, or are.
But successful people,
well, I want to do that
but I don't know how to do that.
But instead of stopping
they say, well then,
my job is to go learn that.
They take their current
limitation and they put it
on their agenda as a job to do.
As a thing to figure out,
a thing to make happen,
instead of saying,
well, I don't have that,
they say, well then, my
job is to go build that.
Or, I'm not like that,
then they say, well then,
my job is to go become more
of that, become that person
who could accomplish those things.
You know, when I was starting
to do online marketing
for the first time and I don't
know how much of my story
you know, but when I started
doing online marketing,
I was literally bankrupt.
And I went from a place
of bankruptcy to the point
where I really committed to
becoming successful at it.
And in 18 months I'd
made 4.8 million dollars,
4.6 collected.
I mean, that's a huge
leap, right, in difference,
from bankrupt to multimillionaire
in the span of 18 months.
But what made that
breakthrough wasn't that I had
new opportunities, it wasn't
that I had new technologies,
it wasn't like, wow,
there's the internet now.
Those things were already there.
I went from this level of thinking
to this level of thinking.
I used to say, well, I don't
know how to build a webpage.
So I said, agenda, figure
out how to build a webpage.
And I spent hours and
hours and hours at nights,
on weekends from my job,
figuring out how to do that.
And I said, well, I don't
have one of those lists,
you know, I don't have any subscribers,
nobody knows who I am.
So I said, job, go build a
list, go get subscribers,
go add value and content
out in the marketplace
and they'll come.
I mean, just keep putting stuff out there.
And I also didn't say, oh my
gosh, well, I have that dream,
I can't have that because
I'm not like that.
Because I wasn't a public speaker,
I didn't know how to do
video, I wasn't like, well,
I'm not one of those video people,
well, I'm not a public speaker.
So I said, you know what, I
have to go learn that art,
I have to go become a better
speaker, a better communicator.
I have to go become more
confident, I have to go become
a person capable of doing these things.
I have to change myself to get there.
I can't wait for circumstances
to change so I can
have my dream.
Then our dreams would never happen.
We have to get to the point
of maturity in our lives
where we say, okay, two things
are going to change in my life.
Something new is going to come
into my life and make me lucky
and blessed and maybe I
can't count on that forever.
And maybe now, instead, I have
to consciously design my life
and say, okay, now, if I want
to change, if I want my dream,
something new has to come from me.
I'm going to become a better person.
I'm going to become a person
who is more optimistic,
who is more confident, who is more driven.
Not because I am that now,
but because we can grow.
That you can become the
type of person who needs to,
who you need to be to
achieve your ideal life.
You can start today, living
from your highest ideals,
your highest sense of self,
your strongest sense of self.
You don't need permission.
You don't need a guy like me
to look at the video camera
and say, you have now permission.
But if you've been waiting
for it, you have permission.
It's like at some point in
your life you just say, okay,
I have permission to become my best self.
And by becoming your best self,
you start to achieve your best things.
You start to contribute better things,
you start to become a better human being.
You can do that now, today.
So next time you're
thinking about a big dream,
don't think about things
that, well, I don't know how
to do that, and stop.
Think, I don't know how.
So set up on your calendar
to go learn those things.
I don't have that.
Then set it up, step-by-step,
to go build that.
I'm not like that.
Then set it up, step-by-step
to go develop those skill sets
and those competencies
so you can become that
and ultimately you can achieve that dream.
It's there, it's waiting for you.
Don't stop.
- Thank you so much for watching.
I made this video because
Priscilla asked me to.
So, if there's a famous
entrepreneur that you want me
to profile next, leave
it in the comments below
and I'll see what I can do.
I'd also love to know
which of Brendon Burchard's
top 10 rules meant the most to
you, had the biggest impact.
Leave it in the comments and
I'll join in the discussion.
Thank you so much for watching.
Continue to believe and I'll see you soon.
(dramatic sibilant music)
- The first think you have
to do in order to improve
your mind is take total
control of your attention
and notice where are
your thoughts right now?
On a very continual
basis you have to think,
where are my thoughts right now?
Are they supporting me?
Or are they automatically
coming up negative
and self-protective in ways
that are not advancing my life?
Just to be aware, to be
conscious of what's going on
in your body, in your sense
of feeling and emotion,
and the sense of the thoughts
you're actually having.
Just start paying attention.
You know, for a lot of people,
because they've never done
this before and it's hard
to remind them to do it,
it's like simple.
Here's what I want you to do.
Just start paying
attention to your thoughts.
Anytime you're in line, anytime
you're in line from now on,
if you're in line at Starbucks, just say,
I'm in line at Starbucks.
Brendon said think about my thoughts.
What are my thoughts saying right now?
Just checking in.
You're in line in traffic
waiting for the next car.
Just sit and think, what
are my thoughts right now?
And just notice what
you've been thinking about.
The more that we notice
what we've thinking about
the more we can interrupt what
we've been thinking about.
See, if we just allow that
feeling to keep coming up
and we don't pay attention to it,
our life can be very frazzled
and very highly anxious.
But once we say, what's
my mind on right now,
and we redirect it, that is
where personal power comes from.
First, awareness, right?
And understanding and the
consciousness to what's going on
but then the ability
now to be self-directed,
to choose what we want to focus on.
So first, we're attentive
to it, and then redirect it.
If it's negative, it's not
supporting you, redirect it.
How do you redirect it?
First and foremost, you just
say what would be the opposite
of this negative thing?
That and you think
about the positive thing
and you focus on that and
you repeat it to yourself.
For many people, that might
include closing their eyes,
just visualizing a more positive outcome.
Thinking about the more positive outcome,
thinking about the more positive outcome,
focusing on it with their eyes closed.
And that visualization of
a more positive outcome
of how things could turn out well,
or how that the situation could be better,
or even just what are the
next steps I should take?
Visualizing that and assigning
a high amount of importance
and duration to it, meaning
making that thing important
to us by making it, how do
you make something important?
You give it a sensation.
You feel that thing.
You sense it.
You sense what your next step would be.
You sense how it would feel if
the outcome would be better.
How would it feel
emotionally, psychologically,
spiritually, for that thing,
allow it to have a lot
of emotion to it.
Pay attention to it, your eyes
closed, you see that thing,
you feel it, you sense a different step,
you know what you're going to do?
You pay attention to it and
you keep focusing on that.
Just over a period of
minutes, keep focusing,
keep focusing, focusing.
When your mind automatically
wants to go back to the easy,
which might be negative,
you go, no, no, no, no,
I don't want, I don't want,
I'm not into easy right now.
I'm into conditioning my mind.
Focus, focus, focus, focus,
given attention, duration,
and sensation to it.
Attention, duration, sensation.
Visualization,
visualization, visualization.
It's repetition of that positive
alternative to a negative
impulse that comes up that
gives us personal power.
You know, so many people
say to me, well, Brendon,
I'm wiped out, I'm tired,
I wish I had your energy,
or whatever.
I know a lot of people don't
want to have my energy,
it's too annoying, I get it.
But what if we had you tap
back into your aliveness again?
You know, what if you just
chooe, not for any reason,
not for what emotions come
up in your human body,
because emotions just come up, right?
Your nervous system, sometimes,
you don't even know why
you feel what you feel.
Like, something can trigger
you, a sound, a movement,
something someone says,
or just your physical body
of what you ate a couple of hours ago.
Or how much you slept three
days ago can catch up to you.
And your body and your emotions
can kind of go psh-drrr.
But we have this saying,
the power plant doesn't have
energy, it generates energy.
What if your dominant
frame said, you know,
I'm going to focus on my
aliveness and you started
cultivating an aliveness in
your body and in your mind
for no other reason than I said so.
No other reason that you
decided to, say, you know what,
today I'm going to focus
on what's great about me
but I'm also going to
focus on being fully alive
and engaged and present.
And how do you do that?
Just, what if you felt
more grateful for the life
that you have?
You know, look, you're
breathing, you're alive,
we have this incredible gift that
we're all here right now, you know?
It's like, I'm here, you're here.
What if we took that seriously
and we started realizing
what a gift it is to be
alive and we allowed ourself
to feel alive, not for any reason.
No one made us happy, no
one did anything for us,
we just felt alive again.
And we started asking
ourselves on a daily basis,
what level of aliveness do
I feel in my body right now?
Do I feel at a level zero, like dead?
Or do I feel like a level
10, I'm fully alive,
fully engaged, fully present?
And we willed ourself into
feeling more alive everyday.
It's the number one question
I get from all of my work.
It's like, wow, you have a
lot of energy on what you do.
How do you get it?
I don't get it, I don't
find it, I generate it.
The power plant doesn't have
energy, it generates it.
If you want to feel
better about your life,
generate more aliveness
for no other reason
that you choose to.
Life should be incredibly valuable to you.
If you really value your days,
like that day becomes valuable.
So, because your day is
valuable, you get stuff done.
You know why a lot of people
end up feeling really broke
is because they're not valuing their day.
They're broke because they
added no value to their day.
They reading celebrity gossip magazines,
they were screwing around
online, they were doing nothing
that actually moved the needle
in terms of their personal
progress and their professional progress.
So value this day!
You want to make more money,
get serious about tomorrow.
Value that day!
Ask how you can add
more value into the day.
Really work the day.
And as you do that over
and over and over again,
you ask how can I serve,
how can I contribute,
how can I take it to the next level?
You do that long enough, pffff!
The breakthrough happens,
the magic happens,
and money takes care of itself.